I mean how about this we went on uh a
different podcast American cholo and we
brought up the fact that there are a lot
of deported veterans and I have a lot of
my friends that don't have papers that
say that they're United States citizen
but they have papers that say they're
United States Marine and that they
served in Iraq and Afghanistan and these
guys aren't being deported because
they're murderers or rapists Kev they're
being deported because they [ __ ] up
some paperwork or because they had a
drug addiction and my stance is
regardless of how you feel about
immigration how dare you tell a person
who stood a post and supposedly served
this country for your freedom whether
you believe that or not because some
people say oh it was all oil Wars
regardless this man stood a post and if
you can throw him out so easily and you
can throw his benefits out right if his
missing hand doesn't mean anything then
you're missing I don't mean nothing
Congressman if you don't if his missing
fingers and his missing jaw don't mean
nothing then your missing legs don't
mean nothing Senator that's the truth
whether it's democrat or republican you
have to pay attention to the people that
have bled for this nation because
Empires don't die because they lose a
war we haven't won a war since World War
II they die because people stop
believing in them that's real that's I
mean that's crazy to say out loud we
have not won I mean we did not win the
Afghanistan war we did not win Vietnam
I mean we tied Korea it was it was a
wash it was a wash all right you can
have that yeah we'll take this yeah
hey guys we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you got
to go to Bluetooth right now sign up for
uh Bluetooth with the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month for
free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient adds Viagra Ana Cialis but in
a chewable form that's right you pop the
blue Chew Chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ]
like you know uh Ryu and Street Fighter
he'd be like he does the [ __ ]
this is gonna be your dick it's gonna be
like why use [ __ ] uppercut you know
what I'm saying God bless whoever's on
the receiving end of that consensually
of course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right